l'or où l'un des biens les plus
convoités de l'histoire métal jaune est
fascinant pour qui des empires ont été
bâties et des civilisations détruites
depuis qu'on a commencé à l'extraire au
coeur de la terre il a suscité des
guerres et des hommes ont tué ou sont
morts pour lui
au 1er siècle avant jésus-christ le
poète roumain virgil nous met en garde
contre l'obsession de l'or qu'ils
appellent la soif maudite
[Musique]
en découvrant le nouveau monde 1500 ans
plus tard un explorateur italien va sans
le savoir lancer le processus de la ruée
vers l'or impitoyable et dictatorial
celle-ci mènera la disparition de toute
une civilisation
le 3 août 14 192 christophe colomb hisse
les voiles pour le plus grand voyage de
découverte de toute l'histoire
il cherche une route occidentales qui le
conduisent jusqu'en asie
contemplant son destin que l'on se met à
prier notre dieu en les mains de qui
tout repose venaient à mon secours
portés mois là où je pourrais trouver
lors deux mois plus tard le 12 octobre
il tombe par hasard sur une île
inhabitée dont il revendique la
propriété pour la reine isabelle et le
roi ferdinand d'espagne sans savoir
qu'il vient de toucher la terre des
futurs amérique collomb pense avoir
débarqué dans ce qu'on appelait les
indes la partie orientale de l'asie
l'une des premières choses qu'il
remarque alors qu'il tombe sur les
indigènes qu'il appelle logiquement des
indiens et que ceux ci portent sur eux
de l'or samedi 13 octobre 14 192
ils ont apporté des écheveaux de fils de
coton des perroquets des flèches et
d'autres choses qu'il serait fastidieux
d'énumérer jeu restait attentif il me
donnait du mal à vérifier qu'il
possédait bien de l'or je remarquais que
certains d'entre eux en avaient un petit
morceau attaché à un trou sur le nez
ferdinand isabelle d'espagne voulait de
l'or il savait que c'est ce dont ils
avaient besoin pour financer pour
maintenir ainsi que pour étendre leur
pouvoir
la revendication d 1,2 par collomb place
l'espagne son voisin le portugal à deux
doigts d'entrer en guerre
quelque quarante ans plus tôt le vatican
a en effet accordé aux portugais a droit
exclusif sur les indes
même si les explorateurs portugais ni
encore jamais mis les pieds sort on est
donc en présence de revendications
contradictoires
et comme les deux pays sont de
confession catholique hu se rendent
auprès du pape afin d'éviter un conflit
l'espagne un avantage de taille le pape
nouvellement élu est alexandre 6-1
espagnol dévoué isabelle et à ferdinand
[Musique]
il a été décrétée qu'on devait tracer
une ligne qui séparait le monde entre
une partie revenant aux espagnols et
l'autre aux portugais et c'est à cause
de cette ordonnance que toute l'amérique
latine par espagnols à l'exception d'une
large partie nord-est qui est
aujourd'hui le brésil où l'on parle le
portugais
si ce partage du globe par le pape
permet d'éviter une guerre il fournit
bientôt à l'europe une excuse pour sa
conquête des amériques
l'une des premières colonies dans le
nouveau monde se situe sur l'île
d'hispaniola
les espagnols que l'on y laisse vont
effectivement y trouver de l'or et par
la même occasion à servir les
autochtones afin de l'extraire
on rapporte cet or à isabelle et à
ferdinand
on trouve une partie de cet or ici dans
l'église santa maria maggiore à rome
c'est en quelque sorte un cadeau de
remerciement du couple royal espagnol au
pape alexandre à la fin du xvème siècle
début 16e
on a refait le plafond si on l'a décoré
avec de l'or dont la tradition veut
qu'ils fassent partie du tout premier or
en provenance du nouveau monde des
américains et lorsque vous regardez bien
ce plafond vous vous apercevez qu'à
certains endroits on dirait
véritablement en or massif
collomb meurt en 15/100 6
convaincu d'avoir touché terre en asie
en lui consacre une tombe au style
sophistiqué a sévi en espagne au moment
où l'explorateur décède
des milliers d'indiens meurent également
à hispaniola mais en bien moins grande
pompe les conditions de vie très rude
ainsi que les maladies introduite par
les espagnols ont fait énormément de
victimes
en quinze 119 la population d' indigènes
a chuté de cent mille personnes à moins
de 3000 ceci ne stoppe pas pour autant
le flux continu d'or vers l'espagne je
dirais que le meilleur exemple qu'on ait
gardé de cette quête acharnée de l'or et
l'ordre que le roi ferdinand deux
d'espagne est censé avoir donné assez
amiraux en partance pour l'amérique du
sud
prenez l'or avec humanité si vous le
pouvez mais prenez le à tout prix prenez
l'or et je pense que malheureusement ils
ont pris ça au mot
ils ont débarqué avec toute une palette
de raison la gloire de dieu la
conversion des non-chrétiens la gloire
de l'espagne la gloire militaire
l'expansion de leur territoire et aussi
l'avidité de richesse ils voulaient de
l'or francisco pizzaro un aventurier
analphabètes figurent parmi les plus
barbares pizzaro appartient une nouvelle
race d'explorateurs espagnol qu'on
appelle des conquistadors
il a déjà suivi pendant dix ans d'autres
conquistadors en amérique centrale en 15
à 123 à l'âge de 48 ans il se sent prêt
à diriger des expéditions citaro a
finalement avoué les choses franchement
je ne suis pas allé là-bas convertir ces
gens tout le monde veut s'en occuper
je suis allé là bas chercher de l'or
pendant neuf ans pizzaro s'échine à
explorer colonisé convertir les natifs
sur toute la côte ouest de l'amérique du
sud
bon nombre d'entre eux se plie à la
domination espagnole ce qui
n'obtempèrent pas sont massacrés en
avaient mis au point une série de
mesures légales appelé le reiki rimando
leur écurie ma nuque tôt voulait que
lorsque les espagnols arrivés dans un
endroit pour le conquérir
il leur fallait d'abord lire la bible
sur place si les paroles de la bible
n'étaient pas acceptées il avait alors
le droit légitime de s'attaquer aux
autochtones puisque ceux ci refusaient
en quelque sorte d'accepter l'oeuvre du
christ
une stratégie qui fonctionne d'un
village à l'autre dans toute l'amérique
du sud
ils se sont aperçus que non seulement ça
leur donnait le loisir de s'emparer de
l'or de ces gens mais qu'il pouvait
aussi exploiter leur main d'oeuvre afin
d'extraire davantage d'or et savez vous
comment il justifié leur geste certes un
conquistador prétendait simplement qu'on
pouvait se le permettre car on avait
affaire à des sauvages
au fur et à mesure que les années
passent leur devient d'autant plus
l'obsession de pizzaro que ce dernier a
entendu une rumeur selon laquelle un
royaume de l'or se situerait de l'autre
côté de l'impressionnante cordillère des
andes
illzach où est prêt à consacrer le reste
de sa vie à dénicher ce royaume
mais pour mener à bien son entreprise il
lui faut une ordonnance du nouveau
souverain espagnol
charles 5 le petit fils du roi ferdinand
et de la reine isabelle en 15 128
pizzaro retourne en espagne chercher le
soutien nécessaire à sa campagne au
pérou
[Musique]
le compte rendu qu'il fait du royaume de
l'or répond en tout point aux
convoitises du roi charles
trois ans plus tard il repart pour
l'amérique du sud
armé d'un nouveau mandat pour s'atteler
enfin à la conquête de l'empiré inca rld
mené par sa soif d'or pizzaro conduit ne
troupe de 200 hommes à travers une
expédition éreintante qui dure six mois
au cours de laquelle ils détruisent des
villages assassine les indigènes et pis
leur or
enfin l'après-midi du 16 novembre 15 132
ils parviennent aux environs de la ville
un cas de cajamarca au loin un mirage
aux lueurs chatoyantes leurs appareils
40000 inca paré d'or d'andorre ces
merveilles en espagnol que leur armée
est aussi flamboyante que le soleil
lui-même les incas utilisée lors pour
fabriquer des objets de rituel des
objets habituel quotidien c'était des
vases des bijoux et surtout des coupes
servant aux offrandes à leurs dieux
qu'on n'utilisait pas dans les
cérémonies les uns qu'un accueil le
petit bataillon espagnol alors que
pizzaro s'apprête à être présenté un
homme que les incas vénère comme un dieu
vivant
l'empereur atahualpa qu'on appelle
l'inca
non pas personnes se seraient avisés de
regarder en face l'inca c'était une
personne divine
il était le fils du soleil un être
complètement au delà de toute dimension
humaine lorsque la toile pas a eu
connaissance de l'arrivée de pizzaro il
lui a offert des présents considéré par
les incas comme des cadeaux de valeur
pizarro a pris la viande de canard
sécher le linge tisser et les autres
objets qui étaient là et s'est exclamé
c'est de la camelote quelle insulte
c'est de l'or que pizza au feu mais ces
soldats sont 200 fois moins nombreux que
l'assemblée qui les entoure
les espagnols se disent alors que s'ils
parviennent à capturer atahualpa vivent
ils se rendront maître de l'empiré inca
tout entier illzach décide donc de leur
tendre un piège sous forme de
proposition de réconciliation
ces hommes ce poste en embuscade
laissant entrer dans la ville une
litière plaqué or sur laquelle trône
l'inca un homme séduisant est musclé âgé
d'une trentaine d'années
wen jiabao doit par walt pas ils se sont
avancés vers atahualpa et le père bar
berthet s'est approché avec sa bible
pour lui lire le fameux récrimine tôt
comme il l'a lui présentait comme
renfermant la parole de dieu atahualpa
s'en est saisie et la pause et contre
son oreille pour voir si le livre aller
lui parler et puis ce qu'il entendait
rien il a jeté la bible par terre c'est
à ce moment précis que pizzaro donné
l'ordre d'attaquer la minuscule armée de
pizzaro se mesure alors à 40 milles 1 k
[Musique]
des archéologues ont découvert au pérou
des crânes humains dont les blessures
avaient été colmatée par un placage d'or
suggérant qu'il existait déjà une
certaine forme de chirurgie du cerveau
pizzaro a offert atahualpa le symbole le
plus sacrés du christianisme la bible au
moment précis où l'un cagettes le livre
saint au sol il en ait décidé du sort de
la civilisation inca
les hommes de pizarro ouvre le feu par
une salve de bousquet puis charge avec
leur ep leur lance les piquer flèche de
bois des incas ne sont pas de taille à
résister aux assaillants
il faut reconnaître qu'à leur arrivée
les espagnols ont déjà un long passé de
combat tels qu'ils ont pu les mener en
italie en suisse et en hollande
les troupes espagnoles sont bien
entraînés elles ont une solide
expérience ainsi qu'une capacité
militaire supérieur en armes à feu en
fer et en chevaux à celle des indiens la
vue de ces cavaliers en armure terrifie
les incas au début il croyait que
c'était des créatures mi homme mi cheval
que le cavalier et son cheval ne former
qu'un seul être la victoire est là plus
inégal qui soit en une demi-heure 5001
casse massacrer les espagnols eux ne
déplore pas une seule perte humaine
illzach où est le seul homme à être
blessé une entaille à la main gauche
reçue alors qu'ils protégeaient
atahualpa contre l'un de ses propres
soldats enragé une fois prisonnier
l'empereur inca essaient de négocier
cette île a conclu un marché avec
pizzaro si ces sujets parvenait à
apporter suffisamment d'or pour remplir
cette pièce on le libérerait il a promis
de remplir d'or la capacité d'une pièce
entière du plafond jusqu'à son doigt qui
la gardent élevé pendant tout ce temps
le peuple inca s'est empressé de réunir
les quatre coins du pérou ces objets et
ornements somptueux qu'ils avaient
façonné de magnifiques pièces d'art
qu'ils ont empilé dans cette pièce
jusqu'à ce qu'elles en soient pleines
plus de 5 tonnes d'or emplissent la
pièce largement de quoi faire de
n'importe quel conquistadors un homme
riche
je crois qu'on a fait l'estimation en
valeur actuelle la rançon hamas et
devait faire entre 50 et 60 millions de
dollars atahualpa a tenu parole pizzaro
lui n'en a pas l'empereur est maintenu
prisonnier pendant un an après qu'on le
juge pour le seul crime d'être 1 1 k il
est condamné au bûcher
les incas croyait on en retour à la vie
il aurait est très important de pouvoir
conserver le corps des défunts
grâce à sa momification atahualpa
supplie alors pizzaro de choisir une
autre façon de l'exécuter ils lui ont
laissé l'alternative de se convertir au
christianisme
s'ils voulaient bénéficier d'une mort
différentes
il a accepté le 29 août qu'un 133 un
moine baptise l'empereur et le nomme
d'hommes francisco atahualpa au moment
précis où il entend prononcer son
nouveau nom l'inca est assassinée par
strangulation
ce qui n'empêche pas pizzaro de faire
ensuite brûlé son corps les trésors doré
inestimable des incas sont ensuite
fondus et le métal précieux a cheminé
vers l'espagne
[Musique]
c'est ça qui est triste on n'a aucune
trace aucune description des objets un
cas qui ont été fondues tout a été
anéantie pour la postérité
la seule chose qui puisse nous donner
une idée de ce qui a disparu à jamais ce
sont ces quelques pièces qui subsiste de
l'art précolombien et qui sont
conservées dans les musées
il s'agit là d'une perte culturelle tout
simplement inestimable trois siècles
durant les espagnols vont gouverner le
pérou ils réduisent le peuple à l'
esclavage rase les villages se livrent
au pillage de l'or mais l'un des plus
grand trésor des incas leur échappe
encore et restera sauf jusqu'en 1911 la
ville sacrée de machu picchu dissimulé
dans un recoin des andes
elle est pratiquement intact lorsqu on
la retrouve machu picchu l'une des
merveilles du monde est une ville taillé
à même la montagne qui s'étale sur huit
kilomètres carrés ces lieux saints ne
sont qu'une poignée à avoir survécu à la
conquête du pérou leurs murs résonnent
encore des légendes de l'or 1 ko raconte
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'histoires sur de
l'or qui serait caché dans la montagne
de l'or caché au fond de lac ou
éparpillées dans plein d'endroits
différents et que les indiens auraient
dissimulé les gens qui s'enrichissent
dans cette région des andes prétendants
général que c'est parce qu'ils ont
découvert lors que les soldats un cas
avait réussi à cacher un pirate met à
sac un empire fondé sur l'or
lorsque les soldats de pizzaro arrive au
pérou atahualpa et son frère oscar sont
deux leaders s'opposant dans une guerre
civile atahualpa en sort vainqueur peu
de temps seulement avant que lui-même ne
tombent entre les mains de pizzaro au
milieu du xvième siècle l'espagne riche
de sa conquête des amériques devient le
premier empire sur lequel le soleil ne
se couche jamais leur afflux énormément
d'espagne vous voyez la quantité
phénoménale d'or que l'on faisait fondre
et comme ce métal ne provenait pas de
mine s'était par la force des choses des
trésors qu'on faisait fondre mais ça ne
leur suffisait pas il leur fallait
encore réduire les indigènes en
esclavage les asservir au travail des
mines afin de produire toujours plus
d'or de l'orc ont embarqué ensuite vers
l'europe pour financer la domination
espagnole dans le monde
l'espagne est devenue très prospère
c'est une époque au cours de laquelle la
littérature se développe c'est le début
d art baroque une période d'opulence
très importante pour la culture
en quinze 156 l'empereur charles 5
délègue le trône à son fils philippe 2
un catholique fervent qui consacre sa
vie à éradiquer d'europe le
protestantisme
afin de financer ses projets philippe
eux va utiliser l'incroyable manne d'or
en provenance d amérique mais en pleine
mer les navires chargés du précieux
métal demeurent des proies faciles en
particulier pour le terrible ennemi de
philippe l'angleterre et avec elle le
plus célèbre de ces corsaires francis
drake
ils ont des pirates très agressif ce
sont des pillards
mais monsieur se disent volontiers
explorateurs ce qu'ils cherchent
essentiellement à partir à la poursuite
des navires espagnols qui transporte de
l'or et de l'argent
ce sont des individus qui ont débuté
comme brigands drac par exemple dont le
but est d'aborder les bateaux espagnols
croisés sur les océans et de piller
leurs cargaisons pourvu qu'elles soient
précieuse éventuellement aussi de faire
prisonnier et d'asservir les marins
espagnols à bord de leurs navires
quand il ne les tuez part au cours des
années 15 170 drake s'attaquent ainsi au
galion espagnol qui parcourt les mers
ainsi qu'aux intérêts espagnols dans le
nouveau monde
il reprend à philippe une partie de sa
nouvelle fortune en or ces hauts faits
sèment la terreur parmi les marins
espagnols et lui valent le surnom de el
draguer le dragon
drake et le corsaire le plus célèbre de
son époque mais aussi un proche ami de
la reine cette elizabeth elle-même la
marraine de la plus rentable de ses
traversées
initié en 15 100 77 un parcours vers
l'ouest qui dure trois ans au cours
duquel ils pillent effrontément navires
et colonie espagnole
ce voyage est aussi la toute première
traversée au tour du monde effectué par
un anglais à son retour en 15/100 80 il
remet à sa reine pour plus d'un demi
million de livres sterling en or
espagnol
si en espagne philippe may a pris la
tête de drake en angleterre la reine
elizabeth le fait chevalier
[Musique]
philippe est hors de lui depuis
l'escurial sa retraite située sur un
sommet montagneux il complote sa
vengeance contre elisabeth et
l'angleterre l'escurial est en partie un
palais en partie un monastère construit
par philippe en 15/100 63 il est financé
par de l'or dérobé aux amériques
philippe consacre ses vastes richesses à
la gloire de son pays
pas la sienne du lever au coucher
c'est un travailleur acharné qui lie
personnellement les rapports sur ces
placements ainsi que les comptes rendus
qui lui parviennent de ses mines d'or
vieux jusqu à l'austérité
il s'habille comme un moine quelconque
ses visiteurs le prennent souvent pour
l'un de ses domestiques
[Musique]
dans les allées les chapelles de son
escurial philippe médite est pris pour
trouver une solution à ces deux grands
problèmes
les pirates anglais et les protestants
anglais
à cette époque là toutes les réponses se
rapportaient probablement plus à la
religion qu'à tout autre chose
elle était le moteur idéologique et les
espagnols en particulier éprouvait une
véritable passion pour leur catholicisme
la réponse attendue lui parvient sous la
forme d'une 'guerre sainte' financé par
son or qui lierait mener directement sur
les terres protestantes ainsi philippe
commence par ordonner la construction de
la flotte de guerre la plus puissante
que le monde ait jamais connu
l'invincible armada
les navires de drake seront cependant
les premiers à attaquer en 15 187 contre
la volonté d'elisabeth
celui ci met le cap sur le port espagnol
de cadix
c'est là qu'ils incendient le chantier
naval de philippe l'assaut est
dévastateur mais philippe fait
reconstruire en hâte son armada l'été 15
188 les voiles de la flotte espagnole de
philippe sont prêtes à être hissé
embarqué à bord de 130 navires
trente mille soldats mettent le cap sur
la motion ils sont accueillis en
personne par le vieux mais 6 de philippe
soeur francis drake promus entre temps
vice amiral
canon et météo anglaise vont ensemble
faire payé un très lourd tribut aux
navires espagnols
lorsque philippe apprend la défaite de
son armada
il plonge la main simplement un peu plus
profondément dans la caisse d'or lors
confère un sentiment de puissance
après avoir rapporté chez eux cet or les
espagnols étaient convaincus qu'ils
étaient devenus les maîtres du monde et
qu'il pouvait avoir réponse à tout
pendant 20 ans philippe continue de
financer sa croisade contre le
protestantisme à l'aide de ses réserves
d'or mais le coût de la domination du
monde s'avère bien supérieur au pouvoir
d'achat de philippe ils ont perdu
progressivement leurs positions de
mettre des océans ce qui a fini par
couper le flux incessant d'or et à
conduire l'espagne à son déclin en tant
que grande puissance
l'or finit par s'épuiser
l'espagne est ruiné le roi le plus
puissant de la terre en est réduit à
faire placer dans les rues des troncs
pour collecter de l'argent
il existe un phénomène récurrent dans
l'histoire de l'or c'est l'histoire de
midas qui avait le don de tout
transformer en or autrement dit en avoir
beaucoup n'est pas forcément synonyme de
bonheur je veux dire qu'on a vite fait
de penser qu'on est devenu puissant
parce qu on en possède
mais en réalité on y est simplement a
servi les nuages de la guerre finissent
par ternir l'âge d'or de l'espagne
et au lieu d'être devenu le pays le plus
riche d'europe
ce qui aurait dû se passer avec toute
cette fortune ils ont fini parmi les
plus pauvres
ils ont littéralement claqué leur argent
on emmène philippe alors âgé de 71 ans
dans cette pièce où il peut contempler
l'hôtel en or qu'il avait dédié à dieu
il reste 50 3 jours torturé par ses
plaies paralysé aveugle d'un oeil
c'est là qu'il meure ses rangs dans sa
main une simple croix de bois
en gros le fait qu'alors que les
espagnols avaient rapporté d'amérique du
sud était habillé en particulier par la
grande-bretagne signifiait que cette
dernière devenait à son tour la plus
grande puissance la plus grande en
termes de positions militaires de part
le monde et je dis militaire c'est dans
le sens le plus large y compris sur les
océans keith est très vaste
trois cents ans s'écoulent avant que
l'or ne provoque une nouvelle guerre
une nouvelle guerre déclenchée par un
colonel américain aux cheveux dorés
le pape sixte 5 promet à philippe ii
d'espagne 1 million de duca en or soit
plus de 30 millions de dollars actuels
si les troupes espagnoles envahissent
l'angleterre une somme dont il n'aura en
définitive pas besoin de faire don par
un après-midi tories de doute 1874 un
messager entre au grand galop d'amphores
laramie wyoming avec une nouvelle
sensationnelle presque aussitôt le
telegraph transmet un message de la
frontière américaine
à la une de la presse internationale
on les a enfin découverte kuster a
trouvé de riches mines d'or et d'argent
dans les collines noir du dakota au
relief accidenté des géologues viennent
de repérer ce qui figure alors comme le
filon d'or le plus important de tout
l'hémisphère ouest sur des terres
appartenant aux indiens des plaines et
bien les collines noirs sont
véritablement le berceau traditionnel
des indiens des plaines en particulier
des lakotas et des cheyennes six ans
auparavant le gouvernement des états
unis avait signé un traité avec les
tribus indiennes lui permettant de les
déplacer des riches terres cultivées des
plaines centrales
beaucoup avaient été réinstallés dans
les collines noir une terre considérée
par les indiens des plaines comme sacrée
s'il fallait tracer une frontière dans
le sable serait était précisément la
région des collines noir
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont exigé que les
états unis inclut les collines noir dans
le traité aussi cinq ans plus tard
des rumeurs se mettent à circuler
voulant que les collines noir abrite de
nombreuses vendor on envoie enquêter sur
place un officier de la cavalerie
américaine le lieutenant colonel georges
amstrong coster le général sheridan lui
a ordonné l'ordre d'effectuer une étude
de reconnaissance dans les collines noir
de partir soit disant voir si ces
rumeurs sur la présence d'or était
fondée ou non
caster va mener une expédition à lacoste
heures
ça faisait vraiment grand pique nique
seulement un pique nique d'environ un
millier de soldats
une centaine de chariots couvert un
canon alors qu'istres sur des chevaux
blancs quelque chose comme seize
musiciens ainsi que deux mineurs dont le
seul but est de trouver de l'or
à leur arrivée dans les collines noir
les soldats se joignent aux mineurs afin
de participer à la prospection le 30
juillet 1874 dans un site surnommée la
french briques une crique française
un mineur trouve au fond de sabathé de
minuscules grains jaune
le surlendemain kuster rédige une
dépêche
on a trouvé de l'or en quantité juteuse
j'ai sur ma table 40 ou 50 petites
particules d'or pur chacune d'environ la
taille d'une petite tête d'épinglé
la plupart ont été recueillies
aujourd'hui dans une seule et même
battait de terre le telegraph a
immédiatement propagé la nouvelle et en
un rien de temps tout le monde a appris
qu'il y avait de l'or là bas les gens
réclamaient à cor et à cri de pouvoir
accéder aux collines noir et bien sûr on
a demandé à l'armée de tenir à distance
ses chercheurs d'or l'armée a donc fait
pression sur le gouvernement pour qu'il
trouve une solution en prétextant
qu'elle se retrouvait à repousser son
propre peuple alors qu'elle était venue
chasser les indiens le général phillipe
sheridan tente de faire respecter le
traité
il ordonne à ses hommes de brûler les
chariots détruire l'outillage et
d'arrêter les chefs souvent les soldats
investissaient le secteur ait demandé à
ces mineurs de plier bagage et de
rentrer chez eux mais ils savaient
pertinemment que les mineurs attendait
en retour qu'ils aient quitté le site
pour reprendre leur travail
un chercheur d'or du nom de john maxwell
se plaint l'unique raison pour laquelle
ces collines ne sont pas encore occupés
c'est qu'on s'attache à satisfaire les
caprices de quelques sauvage misérables
qui réclame que cette magnifique région
restent inexploités à la différence des
incas d'amérique du sud
les tribus des plaines d'amérique du
nord ne voit aucun intérêt à utiliser le
métal jaune s'est cependant l'heure
le bison joué un rôle essentiel chez les
indiens des plaines toutes leurs
cultures tourner autour de l'animal qui
leur fournissaient la totalité de ce
dont ils avaient besoin
leur tante leurs vêtements leur
nourriture leur religion les militaires
savaient bien ça et ils se sont dit que
s'ils tuaient les bisons on éliminait
par la même occasion les indiens l'armée
a donc distribué des munitions gratuite
au chasseur de bisons et les encourager
à abattre l'animal est malheureusement
le bison devient une autre victime de la
soif d'or de l'homme blanc
[Musique]
en 1875 les collines noirs sont envahies
de mineurs le gouvernement américain
abandonne sa mise en application du
traité et décident plutôt d'acheter la
terre aux indiens ces derniers refusent
même les indiens entretenant de bonnes
relations avec le gouvernement savait
qu'il ne pouvait pas vendre les collines
noir en 1875 un fort pourcentage des
indiens d'amérique a déjà été concentrés
dans des réserves
quelques uns résistent encore comme
crazy horse sitting bull
ils ne prennent pas un malin plaisir à
semer le trouble en tirant sur les
blancs il essaie simplement de faire
respecter leurs traditions en même temps
ils sont loin d'être prêts à signer
quelques traités que ce soit ainsi au
printemps 1876 l'armée américaine reçoit
l'ordre de traquer et d'arrêter les
chefs crazy horse est sitting bull puis
de les escorter vers une réserve
loin des riches terrain aurifère l'ordre
émane du même homme qui a découvert de
l'or dans les collines noir le
lieutenant colonel georges kuster kuster
lui-même se vante j'ai de quoi battre à
plate couture tous les indiens de ce
continent grâce à ma 7e cavalerie le 25
juin 1876
les éclaireurs de custer repère un
village indien sur les rives de la
rivière little big horn
il y avait bien 10 mille indiens dans ce
camp au bord de la little big horn le
troupeau de chevaux seul était estimée à
25 mille têtes kuster les a pris
complètement par surprise mais la
situation s'est retournée aussitôt
contre lui parce que les indiens au lieu
de s'enfuir comme le faisait en étaient
les indiens des plaines ont cette fois
contre attaquer
trente minutes suffisent à anéantir les
troupes de caster
la bataille de little big horn
représente la plus importante victoire
des indiens de l'histoire de l'ouest
mais c'est une victoire de courte durée
l'armée voulait sa revanche dans l'année
qui a suivi pas un seul indien impliqués
dans cette bataille n'a échappé soit la
mort soit à sa concentration dans une
réserve dans les collines noir place
nette a été faite pour l'homme blanc en
quête d'or il ne pouvait pas comprendre
la passion des blancs pour ce minéral
leur a fallu beaucoup de temps pour
commencer à réaliser qu'il y avait de
l'argent en jeu avec ses collines les
indiens des collines noir était coupable
de vivre dessus de l'un des plus riches
gisements d'or d'amérique du nord ce qui
était terre sacrée devient le chantier
de la home steak mine la plus riche mine
d'or de l'histoire américaine si le
gouvernement des états unis a offert aux
tribus de les dédommager pour leur
coller noir
celles ci ont toujours refusé pour les
descendants des indiens des plaines
il s'agit toujours de leur terre sacrée
dont aucune somme d'or des blancs ne
pourra jamais compenser la perte
l'angleterre part en guerre pour sa
reine et pour l'or
[Musique]
un dixième de tout leur trouver aux
états unis provient de la home stack
mines dans les collines noir du dakota
du sud en 1886 la découverte d'or sur ce
site d'afrique du sud
métamorphose pratiquement du jour au
lendemain ce trou perdu coloniale la
néerlandaise anp nation la plus riche et
la plus puissante d'afrique
il faut replacer dans leur contexte ces
découvertes en afrique du sud parce que
par la suite près de la moitié de tous
lors jamais produit dans le monde le
sera précisément dans ce pays tout à
coup une région qu'on connaissait pour
ses plumes d'autruche et pour ces tribus
bizarre qui se courait après pour
s'entretuer
cette région devient le terrain de jeu
d'aventuriers accourues du monde entier
en quête de richesse
à la découverte d'or c'est une p
difficile qui s'instaure en afrique du
sud
cinq ans auparavant les bornes parlant
le néerlandais ont réussi à sauver leur
indépendance des anglais la région se
divise désormais entre ces bornes v
république d'afrique du sud et les
britanniques qui forment la colonie du
cap
les hollandais dominer et gérait quelque
chose comme la moitié du pays
l'autre partie restait sous autorités
anglaises mme mais dès l'instant où l'on
découvre de l'or en territoire bord un
afflux de britanniques menace de
submerger la petite république
il était assis sur une sorte de vaste
eldorado et tout d'un coup ils se sont
retrouvés envahi par des milliers de
chasseurs de trésors le nouveau cheval
de bataille de la grande bretagne
consiste donc à protéger ses concitoyens
ainsi que leur mine d'or
même s'il se trouvait sur un territoire
rattaché à la hollande
les premiers investisseurs dans les
mines d'or étaient essentiellement des
anglais kruger les taxes est alors que
ceux ci n'avaient aucun pouvoir
politique
les neuf années qui suivent voit
s'exacerber les tensions entre les bords
et les voisins britanniques
en 1895 cecil rhodes à leur premier
ministre de la colonie britannique du
cap décident de passer à l'action
rod lui même personnellement à la tête
d' immense mine de diamants en voici
sans mercenaires pour tenter de
renverser kruger et son gouvernement
bord mais ils vont endurer une cuisante
défaite en septembre 1899 la grande
bretagne envoie en afrique du sud
un corps expéditionnaire de dix mille
hommes sous le prétexte de protéger ces
mineurs et leur or
[Musique]
le 12 octobre le président kruger
ordonne de mener une grève préventive
6000 soldats bord assiègent les colonies
britanniques de kimberley et de maaf
king et chasse les citoyens britanniques
vers des abris de fortune
parmi les personnes capables de
subsister avec le peu de nourriture dont
ils disposent sept mois durant
figure sarah wilson la tante de winston
churchill
elle garde tout son flegme dans ces
lettres adressées vers l'angleterre
le petit déjeuner de ce matin de la
saucisse de cheval le déjeuner du hachis
et de la viande de mul et des
sauterelles au curry impeccable son
optimisme est justifié on en voit
bientôt davantage de soldats
britanniques en afrique du sud qui
parviennent à lever le siège des villes
anglaises
neuf mois après le début des hostilités
la victoire s'annonce en mai 1940 6000
soldats britanniques sous les ordres du
maréchal l'or de frédérique roberts
ainsi que lord et raciaux kirchner
convergent vers la capitale bord de
johannesbourg il arrive tout près de
l'objet de leur convoitise les terrains
aurifère
sochaux c'est thor était essentiel au
développement futur de l' empire
britannique
économiquement comme industriellement
c'est pour ça que les anglais étaient
prêts à déployer autant de moyens pour
être sûrs de leur victoire
encerclé par une force britannique
écrasante kruger fait alors une
proposition à l'ordre roberts
si les anglais les laisse partir sains
et saufs les bords accepte en retour de
leur abandonner johannesbourg et le
contrôle des mines obert accepte le
marché de peur que les bornes se mettent
à saboter les mines
roberts a déclaré il y à fort à craindre
que les mines et leurs machines soit
endommagée je vous imaginez son
raisonnement
parce que robert comme tous les autres
savaient pertinemment que quand bien
même il faudra reconstruire derrière
lors demeurerait la chose essentielle le
30 mai 1912 mille soldats bord armés
jusqu'aux dents
quitte à cheval johannesbourg et montent
vers les collines environnantes
le lendemain les britanniques entre dans
la ville dont ils prennent possession
ainsi que des mines d'or
le maréchal roberts annonce la fin du
conflit
les derniers mots célèbres il a envoyé
un message à l'attention des
observateurs militaires de différents
pays qui se trouvaient sur place
les américains les allemands les
japonais ou bien les français
il leur a dit messieurs merci pour votre
aide
nous sommes en juin 1900 merci pour
votre assistance vos observations
ça a été un réel plaisir que de vous
divertir tout ce qu'il nous reste à
faire dorénavant c'est de nettoyer le
terrain
vous pouvez donc tous repartir chez vous
mais en réalité les bords ne sont pas
prêts à capituler
si les anglais ont alors eux possède non
seulement un armement parmi les plus
sophistiqués mais aussi la mobilité
c'étaient les meilleurs cavaliers qui
soit depuis l'époque d'attila lin ou de
la horde dorée des jeunes qui avaient
littéralement grandi sur une selle
forte de tous les hommes valides entre
16 et 60 ans l'armée bords commencent
par mener une guérilla
des commandos frappe d'on ne sait où
disparaissant aussi furtivement qu'ils
sont apparus
si vous préférez les bords faisait
presque figure d' ennemi invisible
il ne portait pas d'uniforme on ne
pouvait pas les repérer il ne repartait
pas entre où il mener leur combat puis
se dispersait aussitôt vers leur ferme
c'est probablement la première fois
qu'on utilisait dans une guerre une
tactique de guérilla
cette façon de procéder par raid éclair
sur les anglais est aussi ce qui a fait
éterniser cette guerre pendant deux ans
les bords harcèlent les britanniques qui
investissent encore plus d'hommes et
d'argent dans le conflit en 1901 près
d'un demi million de soldats
britanniques sont postés en afrique du
sud soit dix fois plus que l'armée bord
malgré ces mesures la guerre traîne en
longueur et les britanniques demeurent
incapables de reprendre la main dans un
élan de désespoir
il décide de changer de méthode ils
brûlent les fermes détruisent les
récoltes abattre le bétail
le résultat est dramatique
[Musique]
plus de cent mille femmes et enfants
boers sont rassemblés dans des camps
connu sous le nom de camp de
concentration
c'est la toute première fois qu'on
utilise ce terme
les britanniques avaient décidé de se
distinguer par de nouvelles façons de
mener une guerre qui mettait tout à coup
en cause la population civile
on considère en général cette période
comme celle de l'invention des camps de
concentration on y enfermait les civils
pour qu'il ne puisse pas aider les gens
les statistiques qui prête le plus à
réfléchir sur cette guerre nous viennent
de l'intérieur même de ces camps de
concentration vingt-deux mille enfants
âgés de moins de 16 ans i mourront de
faim et de maladie soit plus que le
nombre de soldats tombés dans les deux
camps
le 31 mai 1902 enfin après quasiment
trois ans de combats désespérés les
bords sont poussés à se rendre par la
famine la victoire des britanniques a
assuré allan pire un flux continu et
conséquent d'or et cela jusqu'à ce que
l'afrique du sud finissent par obtenir
son indépendance en 1948
mais la production d'or revient cher
[Musique]
il était évident que les découvertes
faites en afrique du sud s'annonçait
comme énorme qu'elle allait devenir la
force dominante dans l'industrie minière
de l'or pour les dizaines d'années à
venir et que le n'en voyait pas le bout
de ses mines
certaines ont été exploitées pendant
plus d'un siècle c'était une source pour
laquelle le gouvernement britannique
était convaincu que ça valait la peine
de se battre
aujourd'hui les mym du witwatersrand d'
produisent annuellement pour près de 4
milliards de dollars en or